تقول انها عمليا تحاصر المدينه الجانب
الاوكراني لم يعلن انه انسحب منها او لم
يعلن حتى الان الانسحاب منها ما حقيقه
الوضع في هذه المدينه
الخيارات لم تعد كثيره امام الجيش
الاوكراني اكيد ايضا ان الخناق عسكريا
يضيق في مدينه بخموت ولكن علينا ان ننظر
الى الخريطه لنعرف ماذا يجري راينا
يتحدث عن سيطره على مدينه محمود
ظهر على احد اسطوح البنايات تبين لاحقا
انه في قريه قريبه من مدينه محمود وليس في
قلب المدينه هذه الخارطه الاخيره تظهر اين
اصبح الوضع الان بالفعل عنق الزجاجه يضيق
اكثر فاكثر وكل الطرق التي كنا قد تحدثنا
عنها سابقا بصفتها طرق داد الان باتت
مقدومه تماما من قبل الجانب الروسي الطريق
ام سفر ثلاثه يعني مدينه علينا ان نفهم ان
مدينه هتموت ممتده شمالا وجنوبا وبالتالي
الطريق مثل ام صفر ثلاثه بالكامل تحت
السيطره الروسيه الجزء الاحمر هو كل ما له
علاقه بالسيطره الروسيه هذا هذه الطريق
ثلاثه عشر صفر اثنان وهي تكمل في المدينه
ايضا باتت تحت السيطره الروسيه هذه الطريق
التي لغايه الاسابيع او الايام الماضيه
كانت هناك تكتيكات من قبل الجيش الاوكراني
لعبورها احيانا رغم تعرضها القصف لم تعد
هناك قدره على اخذها لانه بكل بساطه اصبح
التقدم كبيرا جدا للجانب الروسي هذا عاده
طبعا عن الطريق تي 0513 عندما تحدث اليوم
رئيس مجموعه راغنر تحدث عن ابقاء طريق
وحيده لخروج بحسب كلامه الجيش الاوكراني
يتحدث عن طريق تاتي من من هنا عبر لكن
الجيش الاوكراني ومن تحدثت عندما كنت في
كاب الاسبوع الماضي ممن هم في بخموت لا
يثقون تماما بهذا يتحدثون عن سيناريوهات
سابقه اعلن فيها عن كوريدور عن ممر وتم
قصفه لاحقا اذا لنا ان نفهم انعدام الثقه
من الجانبين ايضا ما فهمناه اليوم هو انه
هنا في جسر يسمى جسر قام الجيش الاوكراني
بتفجيره تماما عندما يبدا الجيش الاوكراني
بنسف الجسور كذلك نسف على نهر بخموتك الذي
يقطع المدينه الى جزئين جسر العبور
القطارات هذه تكتيكات سبق وشهدناها من قبل
اوكران في الكثير من المدن ربما اشهر
الجسور له دلاله بعيد تماما عن محمود
نتحدث عن جسر اربيل الذي دمره الاوكران من
اجل منع دخول الدبابات
الروسيه الان نرى تكتيكات مشابهه الى هنا
حاولت ان اق بينما كان الوضع عليه في
بخموت منذ عشره ايام واليوم هذه الخريطه
التي سنراها الان اذا هذا الوضع كان في
الثالث والعشرين من الشهر الماضي منذ عشره
ايام بالضبط لان نراقب تحديدا هذه النقطه
وسوف هل رايت الفارق كيف تقدم الروس من
هنا من حتى في جهات هنا وبالتالي هذا يعني
ان مساله الخروج من قلب المدينه ستكون
دائما اصعب واصعب الاهم من كل هذا انه على
مواقع التواصل الجنود الاوكرانيون كانوا
حاضرين للغايه حاولت ان ارصد ايضا ما الذي
يقولونه لان هناك نوع من الضبابيه من
الجانب الاوكراني هناك من يقول نحن لا
نزال داخل المدينه ما استطعت التاكد منه
هو بالفعل وجود فرقه تحديدا في بلده يهيدن
على بعد اربعه الى خمسه كيلومترات الم
فيها انها تملك مدفعيه هاودزر من عيار 155
ملم هذا الامر مهم للغايه لان هذه
المدفعيه هي الاكثر قدره على احداث اولا
ضرر
ولديها قدره وصول تقريبا تتجاوز الاثنين
كيلو مترا بمعنى انها تبقى قادره على
الدفاع عن محمود ما يبدو الان في الافق ان
نهر المخمودكا الذي يقطع المدينه الى
جزئين يبدو انه سيكون الحد الفاصل علما
انه مره اخرى عندما كنت في ديسمبر في
مدينه بخموت اصلا كان هذا النهر بمثابه
نوع من الخط الاحمر دائما الاوكرانيون
كانوا يقولون
علينا ان نبقي الجانب الغربي تماما في
قبضتنا والجانب الشرقي كانت تدور فيه
مجموعه من
الاشتباكات الان
الدفع ياتي تماما الى الجبهه الغربيه وسوف
نرى تحديدا ما ستكون التعليمات نقض اخيره
احدثت بلبله في الجانب الاوكراني لا يمكن
الا ان نتوقف عندها لان هناك هذا المسؤول
اسمه مديار فاعل جدا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي هو مسؤول عن وحده للطائرات
المسيره التي تلعب دورا هائلا نرى هذا
الفيديو الان ما يقوله في الفيديو انه
تلقى اوامر عليا مباشره بعد منتصف ليل امس
تدعو فرقته الى الانسحاب من بخموت هو يقول
نحن لا نجادل في الاوامر علما اننا مضينا
امضينا في هذه المدينه اكثر من 100 يوم
لكن من الواضح جدا انه كان من الصعب عليها
القبول بالامر ولو انه من الواضح انه نفذه
وانسحبه طيب اي اي ثمن لسقوط بخموت هناك
عده وجهات لهذا السؤال هناك الثمن العسكري
الذي يختلف كثيرون على توصيفه على اعتبار
انهم يقولون ان بخموت مدينه غير
استراتيجيه لكن في حقيقه الامر الهزيمه
المعنويه ستكون مدويه وبالطبع ستفتح
المجال للتقدم نحو
كراماتورسك المدينه الاكبر الثمن الاكبر
قد يكون فيه حال حصل هذا ومن هنا هذه
الاستماته على
نفسه لانه كما لو اننا كنا في مواجهه عن
بعد بينه وبين بوتين في قلب مدينه
بخموت
في اكياس التقيتم بقائد لواء خرج من مدينه
محمود فقط ليتلقى وساما في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير هي الذكرى الاولى
للحرب كان واضحا عندما سالناه كانت يعني
كان يبكي الرجل ورغم هذا الحرج امام
الكاميرا يقول نحن نقول ولكن الثمن غالي
جدا وربما ستكون هناك اسئله حول
هذا التشبث بالمدينه ولكن بطبيعه الحال لا
احد يستطيع ان يلوم قرارا سياسيا بالتشبث
بارض اوكرانيه
الجنب الروسي ايضا يغير تكتيكاته بعد
انتقادات كبيره كان هناك الكثير من
التغييرات التي بحسب المراقبين العسكريين
اتت من وحي من تكتيكات مجموعه التوجه من
مجموعات كبيره الى مجموعات صغيره مثلا
الاعتماد على المدفعيه تكتيكات مدن مختلفه
لكن هذا لم يمنع الكثير من الخسائر
الهائله والاخطاء حتى مثل ما حدث في مدينه
بوليدار مع خسارات كبيره في الدبابات
وغيرها اللافت انه بينما تدور معركه
بخموت هذه الخارطه التي تظهر نقطه مهمه
تحدثت مع برادي افريك قبل قليل وهو مختص
في علم دراسه الاقمار الاصطناعيه والخرائط
هما من قام بهذه الخارطه هذه الخارطه تظهر
كل تعزيزات الخنادق الروسيه
والحواجز من الواضح جدا ان الجانب الروسي
اضافه الى كل المعارك الدائره على كل
الحدود وخلف الحدود ليس فقط الروسيه ما هو
محتل من الجانب الاوكراني نتحدث تحديدا عن
تقاطعات طرقات مهمه مؤديه الى اهم مؤديه
الى شبه جزيره القرم اللافت جدا بالنسبه
الى كل هذا هو حجم العمل الروسي على وضع
هذا الحد الفاصل وهذا ينبئ ربما بالرؤيه
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه بمعنى ما هي الحدود
التي لن تتراجع عنها موسكو وهذا ما
سنتابعه بدقه خلال الفتره المقبله هذه
فقرات وقفه مع الحدث شكرا لك